good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight the news of the dominican
republic getting worse by the day
americans in danger they're now an
american baseball legend is in the
hospital tonight even Fox's own news
crew has come under attack this show is
on the ground for an exclusive joint
investigation into what's happening
there a live report from the dr just
minutes away
but first tonight you probably didn't
read about it over the weekend but it
looks like the president's recent
brinksmanship with mexico actually
worked a week and a half ago the
president threatened to impose tariffs
on all goods coming across our southern
border until the Mexican government
joins us to fight illegal immigration
migration they have been abetting for
years well on Friday they got the
message and caved the Mexican government
will now deploy 6,000 troops along its
southern border with Guatemala and going
forward certain asylum seekers will wait
in Mexico rather than the u.s. until
their cases are resolved now none of
that is going to solve our illegal
immigration crisis but it is at least
potentially a big help and you think
every American would be happy about it
but no Democratic presidential
candidates spent the weekend complaining
about the deal and taking Mexico's side
watch we need a decent relationship with
Mexico they are our allies as is the
case with Canada we should not be
confronting them every other day Trump's
erotic threats and trade policies are
not the way to go the tariffs in general
I thought what happened with Mexico and
the way he used that on the immigration
issue was just not a good thing yeah I
think the president has completely
overblown what he purports to have
achieved by and large the president
achieved nothing except to jeopardize
the most important trading relationship
that the United States of America has so
in case you're trying to follow the
reasoning at home by asking Mexico to
stop encouraging an illegal invasion of
our country were quote jeopardizing our
relationship with Mexico and it's our
fault okay
but the dumbest and most extreme
response came as it always does from
senator Cory Booker of New Jersey having
a border at all Booker explained is very
much like murdering people during the
Holocaust as much as he wants to make us
afraid of people trying to come here
escape be terror not remembering like
when we turn to ray other immigrants
trying to escape terror there was a that
came here during World War two with a
bunch of folks trying to escape the
Holocaust and we turned it around where
they got killed in the Holocaust with a
shame of that we think we would learn
our lesson about people coming here to
seek asylum escaping terror so how do
you even respond to a statement like
that maybe it's best to ignore it but if
you take three steps back what do you
conclude from rhetoric like this well
you probably assume the Democratic Party
loves immigrants but she'd be wrong they
don't so the Democratic Party immigrants
are just a means to an end and of course
the end is always the same power when
immigrants to this country become
pro-american and call for following our
laws as many do by the way the left
turns on them too it happens a lot it's
happening right now - a Gwinnet college
professor called fang zhu zhu is a legal
immigrant from china
he loves the united states he strongly
opposes illegal immigration here for
that activists are demanding that he be
fired from his job professor she was not
giving and in fact tomorrow he'll join
us on this show but the Democratic Party
doesn't want more immigrants like fangs
you they're very clear about that they
want immigration that is based on family
ties anything but merit why because for
the Democratic Party the more desperate
the less skilled the less educated the
potential immigrant is the easier to
control and therefore the better and
that's why in the state of California
right now the government there is
planning to spend hundreds of millions
of dollars to provide free health care
to illegal immigrants that of course
won't help the state of California won't
help millions of a hard-pressed
middle-class Californians but that
doesn't matter
helping regular Americans stop being the
agenda a long time ago